[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to your
fantasy fire drill i am matt camp with
you here at br gridiron get those
questions in because we have two
full weeks of pre-season action now
behind us two more to go you hope maybe
we'll see a little bit more of the star
players playing in this week's action
but we're getting that much closer to
the start of the 2021 nfl regular season
you might be drafting
this weekend if you are i got you
covered get those questions in i'll be
answering them throughout the show i'll
give you my top five tight ends for the
season but before we get to all that
it's time to talk injuries because
there's a lot of injury updates there's
some bad injury updates coming off the
second full week of the preseason let's
get into that but we'll start with your
questions as it relates to those
injuries this is from brian brian norris
wants to know who should i draft first
julio jones or aj brown now julio has
obviously been on and off the injured
port for majority of his career but
comes through but aj brown is the one we
should be focusing on here i still have
aj brown as my top ranked wide receiver
for the tennessee titans coming off an
outstanding year last season and we know
that while julio is great he's a little
bit deeper into his career it is his
first season with tennessee titans i'll
tell you where i have him aj brown wide
receiver six julio jones wide receiver
20 both top 20 players let's just hope
this covert i guess cluster that they're
calling it which now includes ryan
tannehill does not become a bigger issue
for the tennessee titans but aj brown
over julio to answer your question brian
let's get another one of your questions
in right here and uh let's talk to the
man the man wants to know with ntn's
injury would you suggest getting in the
jaguars backfield like i said there was
some bad injury news coming out of the
second week of the preseason and this
was the biggest piece of it travis
antion liz frank injury he is done for
the 2021
season so
where do we go back we go back to james
robinson james robinson may have taken
you to the fantasy playoffs last season
he now with my new rankings comes in at
rb 15 27 overall
and i think you it's somebody you want
to get now i'm not super excited about
the jacksonville jaguars but robinson
has proven and i think you could look at
this team we know trevor lawrence is
going to be the starting quarterback as
he should be you can say that james
robinson is the absolute most safest
play to get from the jacksville jaguars
now with travis ed tien out for the
season by the way travis santian a hold
obviously in your dynasty leagues brian
clay some pretty big injuries lately who
do you suggest me holding on drafting
and who should we stick with let's just
go over these other injuries and a name
we talked about a lot in the first
couple of episodes of this season's your
fantasy fire drill is that man right
there daryl henderson a sprained thumb
coming out of last week now that doesn't
seem like it'll be a big deal he's
day-to-day there the bigger issue is the
fact that the rams traded for sony
michelle from the new england patriots
so it looked like a wide or a locked-in
spot for daryl henderson top 15 rb
potential but now you bring sony
michelle in and that gives me a little
bit more pause i moved daryl henderson
down to rb 21. uh sony michelle maybe
somebody more in the
flex area but it takes a little bit of
that upside away from daryl henderson a
name that i and the entire fantasy
industry has been talking about as a
potential sleeper this year adam
troutman and i guess we all jinxed him
he's out two to four weeks with this
foot injury so yes he could be ready for
the start of the regular season the
saints as i've mentioned outside of
alvin kamara have given me a lot of
pause a lot of moving parts a lot of
change there no drew brees we don't know
michael thomas is really going to be
back to that top four myth ever and it
looked like there were gonna be targets
available for adam troutman knowing they
had moved on from other tight ends well
now he's out two to four weeks he's
still someone i want to get in best ball
leagues but i think now he's more of a
last or second to last round pick i
suppose i suppose somebody maybe you
were getting in the 10th 11th or 12th
rounds moving on from adam trout let's
talk about dak prescott he's a name
that's come up a lot we know that nasty
leg injury had last season but now it's
more about this shoulder the mris
continue to be positive but adam
schefter putting it out there that you
know it doesn't seem like prescott's all
the way there and may not be and that's
given me some cause for concern i still
have met at around the qb5 qb6 spot i am
thinking about moving him down but the
shoulder not the leg being the bigger
concern you know it makes me feel a
little bit better because prescott's
going to be giving you the bonus with
his legs so let's keep an eye on this
situation it just i would like to have a
lot more positive news out of dak
prescott i don't think we're getting
enough of that right now let's move on
to clyde edward solaire according to
head coach andy reed of the kansas city
chiefs edward solaire suffered a slight
ankle sprain in last week's game now i
bring up slight and i put that in quotes
because
if you don't know nothing that comes
from the team outside of the pup list
which we're pretty much passed to this
point has to be
uh official so an injury report that we
hear or any kind of injury updates they
don't really mean anything until week
one when they get locked in yes we'll
see players land on the pup list and
they'll be out for the first six week
season we're not there with edward
slayer i'm just saying
if this is something that possibly
lingers maybe he pops up on the week one
injury report not getting too scared
here uh he is my rb 14 22nd overall a
great rb2 moving on to deandre swift
though and this one is concerning me i
was already concerned by the talk of
jamal williams the 1b to swift's 1a this
groin issue is a problem and it's also a
problem because they're talking about in
detroit the conditioning issue so a
groin issue can always pop back up you
cut the wrong way and you're back to
square one but the fact that the team is
worried about his conditioning
that tells me we could be seeing a lot
more of jamal williams now right now i
have swifted rb17 uh if we don't get
anything positive in the next week or so
i will probably be moving him down and
moving jamal williams up talked about
jamal williams last week as potential
sleeper a little bit of good news more
about reality than fantasy as we go to
indy here for our final injury and
that's carson wentz carson wentz had
that inju foot surgery but now it looks
like with some practice time he could be
ready to go for week one now as i
mentioned last week having some concerns
not great vibes around the indianapolis
coles i think and everything needed to
go perfectly for carson wentz and it has
it now reports from practice since he's
come back have been solid he looks like
he's pretty good now it's only going to
be a couple weeks will he take a little
bit more time to get in step get in tune
with his team that's a possibility
jonathan taylor still only only colt in
my top 100 and i think wentz while you
were probably never going to take him as
someone you're going to throw in your
starting lineup maybe there's a little
bit more confidence him as a qb2 in your
two qb leagues all right let's move on
from the injuries and all that bad news
let's talk about tight ends
and you have questions there it's a
position that's a bit top heavy uh
before i get to my top five tight ends
let's get to your questions uh jay
destino says what is zachary's value
this season uh he is my tight end 21. uh
dallas goddard of course in philadelphia
my tight end nine you know it was a
changing of the guard last year zach
hurts uh and we thank him for this from
the fantasy world has always tried to
play through injuries and i think it's
catching up to him and we saw that last
year and we saw dallas goddard past him
what i think everybody's kind of hoping
for if you have any shares or hurts or
you want to is that it gets traded into
a much more open situation doesn't feel
that way right now not somebody i'm
looking to go after
and it's dallas goddard show for the
philadelphia eagles let's move on from
zach earth let's stay though in the nfc
east because this question comes from
ak10 evan ingram which is basically this
emoji as i'm reading this here uh tight
end 16 to me not somebody i'm looking to
get not somebody with a ton of upside
here you know the numbers last year were
solid now kenny galladay's there take
one barkley is back i've always been a
believer in the fact that ingram has
benefited from the targets he's gotten
because others weren't there
but when others are around he doesn't
become as important he's not someone
that's gonna beat coverage he's not
gonna dictate coverage he's not gonna
scare anybody there uh i just think he's
kind of a guy you know i could see him
plug it in oh i'm stuck this week i need
a tight end but i don't expect ingram to
put up all these top 10 tight end weeks
he's my tight end 16 not exactly excited
about evan ingram with the new york
giants moving on from that one charles
sylvia says is everett a top seven tight
end with russell wilson uh no i have him
at 14 um and
you know there were some good things
that we saw at times from him with the
rams but he goes to seattle now and we
know the talent they have with lockheed
and dk metcalf i still like chris carson
i think he's getting overlooked a little
bit here everett's fine we know what i
think everett will be you pick him up a
week after he scores a touchdown and the
next week he catches two balls or then
he's out of the fantasy realm and he
scores a touchdown when you need dk
metcalf to get the points i think he'll
be more a thorn in the side of people
than be useful for fantasy uh i am not
looking to go get him tight end 14 and
there's some better players with more
upside i would get later on in my drafts
let's get another question here as you
guys are asking about the tight end
position and this is for mets for me
they're for me too when they're actually
playing some decent baseball but we're
talking tight ends here mark andrews tj
hawkinson i like pitts but i don't like
rookie tight end i covered this a little
bit with pitts look it's so rookie i get
that but he's uber talented there's a
ton of targets available in that lin
offense it's not a good team they'll be
throwing a bunch however here's how i
have them ranked uh andrew's four pits
five hawkinson six you can't really go
wrong i'm not really scared andrews is
clearly on the best team in the best
situation i think he's the most reliable
receiver for lamar jackson and the
baltimore ravens as much as they are run
first team and i know they have sammy
watkins there hawkinson now coming into
another season he did a nice job last
year you see the adps are pretty similar
but hawkinson with jared goff now not
matthew stafford i think is a step down
i'm not exactly pumped up about the
detroit lions if you haven't been able
to tell over the last couple shows so we
go andrews pitts and then hawkinson good
question there from mike uh let's get
another titan question here but before
we move into some strategy stuff uh
raider 909 thinking of drafting kelsey
for my number four spot overall okay
then picking up waller if he's available
in round three for my flex stupid gamble
you don't need to do this nobody is
taking travis kelsey inside the top five
if you want to say i'm gonna start my
second round
you're on the turn right you're picking
12 and you get
um
devonte adams and aaron jones an austin
eckler and you come back around you
start the second round those one of
those first couple picks you take travis
kelsey absolutely fine i got no problem
with that but fourth overall no now i
will say this if you have the flex spot
i don't care where points come from and
if you're gonna take darren waller and
you're gonna take travis kelsey you have
two of my top four tight ends on the
season and they perform as tight end one
pluses they are big time players so
thinking that way no i'm okay with
having both those tight ends but i'm not
taking travis kelsey number four overall
let's get into my top five tight ends
for the season and here is what they
look like and a couple of the names i
just mentioned are gonna pop back up
yeah not only is waller in my top four
he's number two kelsey waller george
kittle mark andrews and kyle pitts i
think there's a little bit of a drop off
after that you know we've talked about
guys like logan thomas for the football
team in washington we talked about t.j
hawkinson as well you know a sleeper
like an adam troutman somebody maybe a
little bit more boring
is rob gronkowski perhaps but these are
the these are the difference makers to
me now there's proven names there's
league championship winning names like
kelsey and kittle in there uh i love
what waller's doing with the raiders
pitts is the question mark because he is
a rookie but as i've talked about a lot
the options
are very limited in terms of big time
talent for matt ryan in atlanta so i
like the opportunity that he has there
behind calvin ridley that's where i
stand with my tight ends but
you have more questions and we're
getting to them and we've talked a
little bit about draft strategy so far
so let's get into more of that but your
questions on this before i give you some
of my strategies that i like to follow
see russ 286 i'm in a 16 team league
with snake draft custom scoring what
type of strategy should i be using i
will say this when you say custom
scoring if it favors perhaps there's
leagues that are point and a half ppr
for a tight end so they get a little bit
more maybe you move a kelsey up the
board or a wall or off the board
typically though 16 team leagues that's
as big as you're gonna get
and
at that point as simple as it is you're
trying to get studs it's best player
available maybe you do go a little
higher on the quarterback because it
won't be as easy to stream that position
knowing 16 at minimum or getting used on
a weekly basis maybe you do move a
superstar quarterback up the board a
little bit but it's as simple as going
best player available gathering up studs
trying to focus on teams that you feel
good about teams that you think will be
good all season long those are the
things you want to focus on there's no
real one strategy well 16 team you do
this and this and this and
you're really just trying to load up on
as many studs as you can get because
they will be few and far between in such
a big league let's move on here uh and
now smd is asking here smd 1025 rb's are
top heavy no doubt about it and the
talent drops off in the mid mid-rounds
is it better to draft rb's early
i don't think you need to over value the
running back position i'm going to get
into a little bit more of this as it
relates to my strategy in a little bit
if you end up with a christian mccaffrey
or an alvin kamara
or ezekiel elliot any of these big names
a dalvin cook to me
that actually has me shying away from
taking another running back early
because i know that the wide receiver
position is deeper especially at the top
so i'd rather get more of them because
i'm going in
fully expecting
that hopefully outside of my rb1
i'm going to be working through my rb2
my rb3 a flex spot that's the nature of
the position it is way too volatile it
would be great if you took two tight
ends in the first three rounds and
they're with you the whole way but it's
probably not realistic so i think if i
take one early and i get one that really
has more value you know i think
everybody's gonna agree that christian
mccaffrey has more value than aaron
jones but they're both in the rb1 tier
that's that's fine but if you have that
much of an advantage maybe you don't
have to feel like you have to get
another a running back so early uh good
question though there and a lot of that
continues at the rotting back position
boston mecca wants to know how do i
acquire wide receiver one without
sacrificing all my depth talk to the
worst player in your league and make a
trade it's not that easy and especially
in the preseason everybody's going to be
evaluating their teams differently and
maybe val mike did a great job my draft
or the opposite i did a terrible job and
they're making these massive trades it's
not easy to do what you're trying to do
i don't like to make trades before the
season starts unless something
catastrophic happens and you really have
to deal with an injury or travis ntn
something like that i would rather stay
put and you're probably not going to
acquire wide receiver one without taking
something away from your team one-sided
deals don't happen often but i will say
this you play some mind games you have
somebody you know let's say you're a
cowboys fan you got a cowboy you know
you got a cowboy on your team and
somebody in your league's a cowboys fan
you try to play with their heart that
way that's the best way to do it but
you're probably not going to fleece
anybody for a wide receiver one another
one here uh let's go to tyler tyler
wants to know i go rb
in round one receiver round two then our
being receiver rounds three and four qb
and five is that smart no and you can't
plan this it's never worth planning four
five rounds deep the board is going to
fall different ways everybody could be
sitting in a draft room with different
kind of rankings there could be with
this idea if i go rb round one let's say
you're picking on top three or four sure
and you go receive a round two what if
it was a big one run of receivers after
you picked that running back or maybe
there's a a great wide receiver you
didn't expect to be there in round one
and then you say three four you can't go
by this you can't lock yourself into a
strategy different things will happen
you can't predict what will happen if
you're picking in the top three you
might go okay i'm gonna get a big
running back i'm gonna come back around
and i'm gonna have that turn so maybe i
go you know i got that big running back
i don't have to get another one but i
might love a running back that's there
in my second or third round or i might
hate it it's not worth planning that far
ahead you got to let the board come to
you and sometimes you look at adps and
it doesn't match up to what your board
looks like and ends up looking a lot
better don't try planning that far ahead
it's not worth it at all and let's get
one more in here as it pertains to draft
strategy before i give you mine uh this
is uh q excuse me oe 509
what round should i pick up a
quarterback i never go get a quarterback
early in your typical redraft leagues um
it's not a position i consider really to
the seventh or the eighth round i will
let others take patrick mahomes and josh
allen and lamar jackson
i don't necessarily want to stream the
position but i know i can do that in
your 10 your 12 even your 14 team
leagues for the most part i'm looking at
quarterbacks that are in the bottom of
the qb one tier we'll talk a little bit
more about them coming up right now
because i want to give you
my personal
best draft strategies let's get into
these here and as i start with it's
still okay to wait on a quarterback i
have used this strategy for years
whether i get somebody i like or i don't
get somebody i like and then i'm gonna
stream the position i have won fantasy
championships with josh mccown i have
won fantasy championships with derek
anderson and you can do the same a
backup quarterback or somebody that you
weren't even considering right now as we
sit in august could end up playing into
a pretty solid role late in the year or
just have a good matchup in the fantasy
playoffs and you play them and work but
i'll give you some adps brady's at 78
right now stafford around 92. jalen
hurts at 88 9.5 these are much further
down the board and you're going to be
fine grabbing these players and guess
what tom brady is going to put up some
top five weeks now they're not in the
top of the qb one tier but they're still
in solid spots let's move on to another
one here don't over invest in
questionable situations now i'm not
saying you can completely avoid bad
teams but the texans right now who knows
what's going to happen with the sean
watson not exactly a talented team the
lions right now it's jared goff we heard
you know earlier about deandre swift an
awful wide receiver group the eagles
right now yes it's hertz but how good do
you feel about the philadelphia eagles
right now who do you confidently draft
on that team outside of miles sanders
ago that person is going to help me win
a fantasy championship the jets there's
some intriguing young talent there i
know the coaching staff has put on a
pretty good first impression but i don't
feel great about that and the jaguar is
another one i throw in trevor lawrence
is starting they just lost ntn it's a
very mid-range wide receiver group to me
as a whole these are situations where if
you get one of the players he seems fine
but you're not getting two or three go
load up on the chiefs go load up on good
teams that's fine go get a couple of
packers if that's how it works out
that's fine if you get stephon diggs and
josh allen probably won't happen good
for you those are the teams that you
want to get multiple pieces of uh shoot
higher with later round picks because
guess what if they don't work out you're
going to get rid of them anyway don't
fret over this you know i'm taking a joe
burrow over a kirk cousins i'm taking
even though he's banged up adam troutman
you know later on than an evan ingram
i'm gonna look at a kenyan drake over
someone
like a james connor or david johnson and
a kenyan drake to me in vegas let's say
josh jacobs goes down or kenyon drake
really carves out a pretty solid role uh
because he's a good pass catcher james
connor is is a guy in arizona david
johnson as i mentioned the texans it's a
bad team give me some upside later on
any player that you're taking in the
11th 12th round and beyond that they
could very well be off your team in
three weeks so shoot high for that and
if it doesn't work out they are lottery
tickets and guess what you'll throw away
a lottery ticket if it doesn't work and
finally this is more about a long-term
approach you're gonna be working on that
running back position
all season long you could come out of a
draft that you do this weekend ago my
running back group is phenomenal i'm
gonna win a championship
and two of your top three players can be
gone within the first month month and a
half of the season okay then the draft
doesn't mean anything because you're
going to have to work that wave wire let
me give you some examples of running
backs that help people win fantasy
championships last year jeff wilson and
jd mckissick were top
10 fantasy running backs from weeks 14
through 16 last year yeah we weren't
talking about them
at this point last year but look what
the waiver wire can do
tony pollard stepped in last year for
zeke he was rb 14 in the fantasy playoff
weeks think about antonio gibson last
year think about james robinson mike
davis stepped in for christian mccaffery
and played at an rb1 level
so the running back position especially
in your drafts is not one that is
probably gonna say
solid and static all season long you're
gonna go to the waiver wire for your
running backs as good as you might feel
about them right now and the waiver wire
is going to help you win a championship
more than ever the draft and what it
means to your success that is dipped and
the waiver wire means so much more
especially at the running back position
so those are some of my draft strategies
but let's get to your burning questions
here kind of a potpourri of questions as
we'll start to wrap things up uh college
ball with all the elves hopefully it'll
take those in the season would you draft
devonte adams or aaron jones jonathan
taylor in a full ppr league very simple
here uh here's where i have it adam is
my
adams is my highest uh player of the of
that group by far by a few spots aaron
jones will be next then jonathan taylor
but devonte adams as soon as we found
out that aaron rodgers was coming back
it was very easy to throw him inside my
top three at the position in fact i
think he'll be in number one overall adp
of 8.5 in the second half of the first
round a couple of spots better than
jones and about four or five spots
better than jonathan taylor you draft
devante adams with confidence at least
in 2021 because who knows where aaron
rodgers will be going forward uh muns in
a pr league i just accepted a trade
where i get cooper cup and chase edmonds
but i trade mike davis and t higgins
what are your thoughts um a pretty good
trade here and i'll tell you why i think
you're getting the best player of the
deal it's a pretty even deal you see the
numbers for cooper cup there
last year see the adp i mean i'll just
say right now cooper cup wide receiver
16 40th overall for me chase edmonds
rb27 64th overall mike davis rb 25 59th
overall t higgins rb a wide receiver 24
61st overall i mean i'll say that
edmonds and davis are close but i think
you get the upgrade in cooper cup over t
higgins so i will say this month's
congratulations
on my opinion you won that deal not
often do i like making deals this often
but or this early but you got the job
done and it works out here based on what
you're giving up as we see here with
mike davis i like what i saw from t
higgins last year but i think you're
doing a better job uh with the tandem
that you've acquired in this train let's
get another one in here and we're going
to move on to nate uh nate wants to know
will antonio gibson be a boom or a bust
antonio gibson may have helped you win a
championship last season i think he will
be a boom yes we mentioned jd mckissick
before but he is far far far away from
antonio gibson uh i don't love the
washington football team but they have a
good defense which means gibson will get
his touches on the ground and through
the air 11 touchdowns probably a tough
number to replicate on a team that's i
would say middle of the pack but i i
will tell you right now i have him at
rb11 that's a low end rb1 to me i like
him i think he's a good player the lack
of competition around him is a good
thing so i will say much like last year
although coming in with much higher
expectations antonio gibson will be a
boom for you in 2021 nate good question
there let's get a couple more in here
before we wrap things up and this is
from xx niners is chris carson worth it
this year hey can we put a little
respect uh niners i know he's in the
same division ch alright spell the man's
name right because he has been a great
running back for many years now yes rb
1939 overall chris carson for the last
couple of years has been a perfect rb2
to me he's reliable he's on a team that
trusts them rashad penny's not really
that good who i have by the way at rb 59
186 overall chris carson just gets the
job done he's going to give you some rb
one level weeks more often than not but
you can get him as an rb2 on a team that
trusts him and i know pete carroll lies
all the times about his all the time
about his tight ends about his running
backs but chris carson remains kind of
someone that doesn't get enough respect
in either fantasy or reality yes i like
chris carson with the seattle seahawks
one more question here before we wrap
things up in the third edition of your
fantasy fire drill in 2021 uh bill's
mafia in my keeper league do i keep
calvin ridley in the fifth round or josh
allen in the tenth round in a vacuum
they're both
outstanding values but i'm always
keeping the wide receiver because calvin
ridley could be a first-round pick josh
allen probably fourth or fifth round
calvin ridley no more julio there it's
just look at the numbers he put up and i
know julio missed half the season
basically last year but the numbers are
outstanding and based on adp alone
20.8 that's the second round
you're keeping him in the fifth and i
think he could be a first round player
it's a home run to me you could always
find the quarterback you didn't say
dynasty you said keeper so you're gonna
keep calvin ridley there and you're not
gonna think twice about it bill's mafia
thank you for that question maybe a
little homer there with the josh allen
part of it well guess what i got one
more of these to come it'll be next
thursday
1 p.m eastern we'll have more important
pre-season action to come continue to
get your questions in on the br app and
we'll take you to a fantasy championship
in 2021 i'm matt camp and this has been
your
fantasy fire
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you